ALEX LEWIS: I love
swimming because it really
allows me to be
myself and just focus
on myself for
whatever time period
it is that I'm practicing.
It's one of those few
activities where you're really
just thinking about every
single part of your body
and how it's moving
together in sync.
I'm Alex Lewis in
the Class of 2018,
majoring in computer science
with a certificate in society
and technology.
I started swimming when
I was six years old.
I was always like spending
summers like around lakes,
oceans, stuff like that.
Swimming is an escape.
Every coach I've had
has always told me
that you should come to practice
just thinking about swimming.
And it's just you
focusing on your stroke,
focusing on yourself.
Swimming really provides
that escape for me.
COACH: [INAUDIBLE].
Sprinters, start
filling your lungs.
There is no air on number one.
ALEX LEWIS: I think there
is definitely a relationship
between swimming and academics.
I think swimming forces you to
manage your time efficiently,
be on top of your work,
to stay organized.
Swimming is -- the sport
itself is -- it's very physical.
And it is entirely you pushing
that mental barrier of getting
through something challenging.
And that is completely
relatable to the way I've
been approaching my schoolwork.
I think it's made my life
at Princeton much easier --
just both of them
compliment each other
and have taught me lessons that
I've been able to use in both.
I think if I
stopped swimming, it
wouldn't make me
a better student.
My best grades and my best
work is done when I'm swimming.
It's the same thing,
basically, from here, just
on a smaller scale.
Like ignore that.
I'm majoring in computer
science because I
think it's something I've been
just -- technology has just
always fascinated me
since I was a little kid.
I think my certificate,
society and technology,
which is through the Center for
Information Technology Policy,
really like opened up my
eyes to the kind of policy
viewpoint of computer science.
The most interesting
class I've taken
was called "Data
Structures and Algorithms."
Every lecture, they focus on
how that like topic that you're
learning for that day is being
used in some relevant standing
in the world today.
Princeton has taught me
to swim for something
greater than myself.
And I would say that's what the
Princeton swimming experience
specifically is about.
You know, we see each
other on the pool deck.
You just notice that
there's something
different about
the Princeton guys.
And it's that we
really are having fun
and that we're doing
it for each other.
It's been really
special to have that.